did you know the global average cost of
a breach is 4.24 million usd and it
takes on average 287 days to identify
container breach
the problem is many of the tools in the
marketplace today fail to adequately
stop and prevent breaches
hi my name is tim brainer and i'm with
ibm cloud
today i have the honor of talking to you
about the ibm cloud security and
compliance center and how it can help
you solve this problem in one view
as customers encounter moving regulated
workloads to the cloud they have to keep
several things in mind and achieve
they want to manage risk
and compliance with as much automation
and standardization as possible to
increase effectiveness and lower costs
they want to ensure data protection with
concepts like zero trust
by implementing least privilege for
their identity and access management or
ensuring storage is encrypted
they want to automate continuous
detection and response for their
misconfiguration of cloud resources
to reduce the probability of being the
next big data breach in the news
they want to make it simple to infuse
security and privacy for their cloud
developers with devsecops
but before we get into ibm cloud
security and compliance center first we
have to talk about cspm or cloud
security posture management
it is a category of security products
designed to identify misconfigurations
and compliance risks in the cloud
cspm tools work by examining a cloud
environment against a defined set of
best practices
and known security risks
it helps cloud applications be more
secure
and ensure compliance with regulatory or
corporate compliance standards
we have a video entirely on the cspm
subject done by one of our great team
members jaina vane
what is sec scc is ibm cloud's answer
for simplified and centralized security
and compliance posture
it is geared for enterprises with
regulated workloads needing to
accelerate public cloud adoption we want
your workloads to be secure by default
with the easiest onboarding experience
that's why we made sec part of the ibm
cloud platform
no installing no instances to provision
just there by default and with every ibm
cloud account from there it's simple to
start seeing results
ibm cloud is the only cloud service
provider that has the ability to scan
other clouds the only one that has depth
in ibm cloud
and continue to expand our hybrid
multi-cloud capabilities with ibm cloud
satellite
sec is the central way to proactively
enforce or prevent misconfiguration for
all ibm cloud services
all this while providing the best level
of production experience
stable reliable scalable and extensible
through apis and terraform templates
as well as integrations with cool
leading partners like tanium cavionics
new vector twistlock and our openshift
compliance operator
so let's dig in
first how do i access scc
well
it's easy as logging into cloud.ibm.com
and go into the left hand hamburger menu
to find security compliance or in this
example you can click on the security
and compliance widget that gives you a
quick snapshot of your security score
and opt detractors
or you can click manage in the top lab
and select security and compliance
once you get into the sec experience
there's several ways to get started we
have several examples videos and links
directly to documentation
and besides we're constantly making
onboarding experience easier and easier
when monitoring for configuration
compliance
you'll start off by selecting a
predefined profile or creating a profile
of your own
a profile is a grouping of control
implementations that we call goals
once you have what you want to check
you'll need to identify what resources
you want to run those checks on we call
those set of resources a scope
then once that is ready you'll set up a
collector and scan details
at that point you have an automated scan
providing continuous compliance and your
compliance score so let's say you're
monitoring but want to be a little bit
more proactive
that is where our configuration
governance capabilities come into play
configuration governance enables you to
define manage enforce and monitor the
configuration rules of your ibm cloud
resources
it's set up by defining customizing and
enabling those configuration rules or
you could group them together in what we
call configuration rule templates
once you have set up compliance scans
enabled configuration rules and set
security alerts you'll have a nice
dashboard like this one
this one dashboard provides a quick view
of all three capability areas of sec and
allows you to manage your security and
compliance posture from one place
or if ui is not your thing we have a
full list of apis and clis available to
interrupt with your security tools
so there you have it you just had a
whirlwind tour of the ibm cloud security
compliance center honestly there's so
much more value inside of it that i want
you to go check out but just keep this
in mind
it's ibm cloud's answer for centralized
security and compliance posture for
enterprises with regulated workloads
needing to accelerate public cloud
adoption
thanks for watching and hope to catch
you on the next video